you guys are for sure so you heard about
the announcement Michelle Waterson and
you Lana and Jake yes sober 12 shells my
gals pn+ 19 that's a crazy crazy fight
yeah dude so yeah they're matching up
the verbal oh no good for me I don't
know either them but I'll look at how
look at the pictures of them and I'll
tell you who was based on the posse
accuses what Lovato of peds everyone's
been saying that I don't know a fans
insane dude two great fighters you're
honoring Jenn Jake is no joke I love her
but I love Michelle - I'm so happy for
Michelle because this was she was
looking for this
no Michelle is she do you think yes ty
yeah and I believe white so I have to
beso to you because I'm Korean and Irish
I have to go for her but I would I would
think that the bookworm is unsuspecting
yeah well there nah she's an assassin an
assassin she's an absolute assassin but
Michelle's game I think his way more
diverse really got a lot more to offer
really say your money's out Michelle
my money's on Michelle Michelle was
yoked she's jacked
Michelle is mr. ty it's her time when is
it October 12 yeah you wanna yet it was
hard to beat though she is a kind badass
that's a great fight I'm really looking
forward to that um I don't know if she's
actually half white but she does look
half white kinda yeah I was like I
talked to either one of these John could
destroy like 80% of the Comedy Store
right okay until they got to like yeah
you guys well then I'd be like she's
slipping I'm trained by Tariq Aziz if
you I stepped in the ring with either of
me I'm not sure good smoke and I make
any comment but the answer is but the
answer is the answer is yes I would
I believe that they would be Mia yeah I
would man I wouldn't last a second it's
worth this race what they do yeah all
the time so I mean don't kid yourself my
boxing is scary yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
Oh [ __ ] business